This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I live in Northern California, and when it comes to camping in the backcountry up here, bears are always something you plan for. The best way to avoid bears is to not attract them in the first place, and that means putting your food and any fragrant items into a bear canister. But how do we know that bear canisters actually work? For decades, product testers would assess the bear resistance of a canister, by dropping a weight on it from a set height, or by trying to puncture it with a spike that simulated a bear's tooth.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。我住在北加州，在这里去野外露营时，熊总是你需要考虑的问题。避免遇到熊的最好方法就是从一开始就不吸引它们，这意味着要把你的食物和任何有香味的物品放进防熊罐里。但我们怎么知道防熊罐真的有效呢？几十年来，产品测试人员会通过从设定的高度向罐子投掷重物，或者尝试用模拟熊牙的尖刺刺穿它，来评估罐子的防熊性能。
But they kept running up against a problem. These tests weren't close enough to reality. They weren't accounting for a bear's creativity and resourcefulness. So then, in the early 2000s, they hit upon an idea of testing the canisters by using something slightly more realistic. Bears. A manufacturer would say, I have this new design for a bear resistant canister that I want campers to use.
但他们不断遇到一个问题。这些测试不够接近现实。它们没有考虑到熊的创造力和足智多谋。因此，在21世纪初，他们想出了一个通过使用稍微现实一点的东西来测试罐子的主意。熊。制造商会说，我有一个防熊罐的新设计，我想让露营者使用。
They bring it to this bear sanctuary. They fill it up with bear treats like fish and honey and all sorts of goodies. And they just throw it to a grizzly bear. This is journalist Alex Davies. He says that these bears will bite, chew, claw, and jump up and down on these products. If a product gets through one hour of contact with a bear and isn't open, it gets certified as bear-resistant. Some bears are more successful than others.
他们把它带到这个熊保护区。他们往里面装满鱼和蜂蜜之类的熊爱吃的零食，以及各种好东西。然后他们直接把它扔给一只灰熊。这是记者亚历克斯·戴维斯。他说，这些熊会咬、嚼、抓，并在这些产品上跳来跳去。如果一个产品在与熊接触一小时后没有被打开，它就会被认证为防熊产品。有些熊比其他熊更成功。
And the most famous of these bears, his name is Kobuk. Cobok became Kobach the destroyer because he was the best. As a cub, Kobach was dubbed a problem bear for getting into human food. He was removed from the Alaska Wilderness and brought to a sanctuary where he and his fellow problem bears were put to work. And there, instead of becoming proper, problem bears, they became problem-solving bears. Because the work of the bear sanctuary wasn't just to keep bears safe. It was actually to have those bears test out supposedly bear-resistant products.
而这些熊中最著名的一只，它的名字叫科布克。科布克变成了“破坏者科布克”，因为它是最厉害的。作为幼崽时，科布克因为偷吃人类食物而被戏称为“问题熊”。它被从阿拉斯加荒野中带走，送到了一个保护区，在那里它和其他“问题熊”同伴被派去工作。在那里，它们没有变成规矩的“问题熊”，而是变成了“解决问题的熊”。因为熊保护区的工作不仅仅是为了保护熊的安全。实际上，是为了让这些熊去测试那些所谓的防熊产品。
Cobok, above all other bears, became known for his ability to break into almost anything. If your product survived Kobuk, it might even get written up in a local paper. Cobok was more a destroyer of ego and of product design than anything. He was just really good at it. Alex Davies is the author of the new book, Kobuk, The Destroyer, and other tales from the wild and unseen world of test engineering. His book takes us through the long history of how things are tested and all the behind-the-scenes work that goes into making sure things work.
科布克，在所有熊中，以能够闯入几乎任何东西而闻名。如果你的产品在科布克手下幸存下来，它甚至可能会被当地报纸报道。科布克与其说是破坏者，不如说是自我和产品设计的破坏者。它只是真的很擅长。亚历克斯·戴维斯是新书《科布克，破坏者，以及来自测试工程野外和未知世界的其他故事》的作者。他的书带我们回顾了事物是如何被测试的悠久历史，以及为确保事物正常工作而进行的幕后工作。
And I constantly felt like an emotional pendulum. where one day I'd feel like everything is crap. Nothing is tested properly. They're all cutting corners. They're just trying to make a profit. And then the next day I'd read a different example. I'd go, oh, my God, these engineers are heroes. The work they put into figuring out to make this thing safe for my kid is incredible.
我一直感觉自己像个情绪钟摆。有一天我觉得一切都是垃圾。没有什么是经过适当测试的。他们都在偷工减料。他们只是想赚钱。然后第二天我读到另一个例子。我会说，天哪，这些工程师是英雄。他们为确保这东西对我孩子安全所付出的努力是不可思议的。
And obviously, like all things, the truth is probably somewhere in the middle. But I do think that for the most part, you can come away. with a sense of awe that there is all of this work that goes into not making something but making it work. I think when people, certainly when I picture product testing,
显然，像所有事情一样，真相可能介于两者之间。但我确实认为，在很大程度上，你可以带着一种敬畏感离开，因为有这么多工作不是为了制造某样东西，而是为了让它发挥作用。我想当人们，当然当我设想产品测试时，
I don't picture a bear. I picture like a man in a white lab coat maybe with eye protection on and he's dropping a bowling ball on a hard hat to see if it indoors such treatment. In your book, I think you roughly classify this kind of testing as limit testing.
我不会想到一只熊。我会想到一个穿着白色实验服的人，可能戴着护目镜，他正把一个保龄球扔在安全帽上，看看它是否能承受这种处理。在你的书中，我想你大致把这种测试归类为极限测试。
Could you describe limit testing and its origins. Limit testing is probably the most basic kind of testing. You're examining a product usually for its strength and for its durability. So it's everything from how far can you bend the wings of a 777 Boeing airplane before they snap to how many times can you hit the space bar on your computer before it breaks. the understanding of a product's limits has been around as long as people have been building stuff.
你能描述一下极限测试及其起源吗？极限测试可能是最基本的测试。你通常是在检查产品的强度和耐用性。所以这涵盖了从在波音777飞机的机翼折断前你能弯曲它们多远，到在电脑空格键坏掉前你能按多少次。对产品极限的理解和人们制造东西的历史一样悠久。
Everyone knew that if you're building a new bridge, it has to be really strong. But the actual work of limit testing, of trying to figure out in a scientific way with a rigorous method of evaluation, I trace that back to the foundation of the underwriters' laboratories, which came about in the very beginning of the 20th century.
每个人都知道，如果你要建造一座新桥，它必须非常坚固。但极限测试的实际工作，即试图以科学的方式、用严谨的评估方法来弄清楚这一点，我将其追溯到保险商实验室的建立，它出现在20世纪初。
And that was started by a guy named W.H. Merrill, and he had this idea of people are terrified of electricity because it sets a lot of stuff on fire. This was an age when entire cities were still burning down on a fairly regular basis. and also at the same time, a lot of electrical appliances were coming into the home. Before you had an electric iron,
这是由一个叫W.H.梅里尔的人发起的，他有一个想法，人们对电力感到恐惧，因为它会引起很多火灾。那是一个整个城市仍然相当频繁地被烧毁的时代，同时，许多电器也开始进入家庭。在你拥有电熨斗之前，
an iron was a chunk of iron, but you got really hot and you pressed it on your clothes. That's why it's called an iron. And now all of a sudden, electricity was coming into the home, and Merrill saw this business opportunity to say, like, hey, what if I actually tested these things, to make sure they're not liable to set your entire home or your entire city on fire.
熨斗是一块铁，你把它弄得很热，然后压在衣服上。这就是为什么它被称为“铁”。现在突然之间，电力进入了家庭，梅里尔看到了这个商业机会，他说，嘿，如果我真的测试这些东西，确保它们不会导致你的整个家或整个城市着火，会怎样？
And he created a whole business out of this. Underwriters Labs has always been about testing a product against the manufacturer's claims. And so within 15 years or so, they were testing millions of products a year. And the products that passed got the Underwriters Labs seal of approval physically stamped onto them. And that became a real market.
他围绕这一点建立了一整套业务。保险商实验室一直致力于根据制造商的声明来测试产品。因此，在大约15年内，他们每年测试数百万种产品。通过测试的产品会被物理盖上保险商实验室的批准印章。这成为了一个真正的市场。
of consumer trust at a time when electricity coming into the home, all new kinds of products coming into the home, created a new kind of risk. And test engineering rose to meet the challenge of that risk. Yeah. And this, you know, this mark of Underwriters Laboratory, that, you know, it really mattered to consumers and to retailers. It became a huge deal. There were entire cities. I think Los Angeles was one of them. And store chains like J.C. Penny, which existed at the time that said, you can't buy an electric appliance if it's not UL approved. It has to have that stamp on there. I mean, to do this type of testing, you need a lot of standardization, right?
在电力进入家庭、各种新产品进入家庭创造了一种新型风险的时代，这成为了消费者信任的市场。测试工程应运而生，迎接了这一挑战。是的。而且，你知道，这个保险商实验室的标志，它对消费者和零售商来说真的很重要。它成了一件大事。有整个城市。我想洛杉矶就是其中之一。还有像当时存在的J.C.彭尼这样的连锁店，它们说，如果不是UL认证的，你就不能购买电器。它必须有那个印章。我的意思是，要进行这种类型的测试，你需要大量的标准化，对吧？
How did Underwriters Labs go about making sure everything was tested in a way that was considered fair and trustworthy? They kept incredibly detailed handwritten reports at the time of just exactly what it did when they were testing. safes, for example, which the big thing with safes at the time was, one, so that they could keep burglars or out, out. But they were also really important for resisting fire, because if your building caught fire and all of your business papers were in your safe, it was hugely important that all of your business records didn't burn up. So a lot of the testing they did on safes was fire resistance. It wasn't just, we're going to heat this thing to 1,500 degrees Fahrenheit and see what
保险商实验室是如何确保一切测试都以被认为是公平和值得信赖的方式进行的？当时他们保留了极其详细的手写报告，记录了测试时到底发生了什么。例如保险柜，当时保险柜的大事是，第一，为了把窃贼挡在外面。但它们对于防火也非常重要，因为如果你的大楼着火了，你所有的商业文件都在保险柜里，那么你所有的商业记录没有被烧毁就非常重要。所以他们对保险柜做的很多测试都是防火测试。不仅仅是，我们要把这东西加热到1500华氏度，看看会
happens. They had a very specific heat over time gradient. And it was this chart. And it said, after three minutes, it should be 90 degrees. After four and a half minutes, it should be 115 degrees. And that's how meticulous they were in their testing. Yeah, it brings up this interesting dilemma. I mean, I just wonder how manufacturers and testers decide how safe is safe enough. Like, how reliable is reliable enough? How does this line get determined for each product? If you look at different products, it's always a sliding scale. An airplane has to be more reliable than your laptop's keyboard. Right?
发生什么。他们有一个非常具体的随时间变化的加热梯度。这是一张图表。它说，三分钟后，应该是90度。四分半钟后，应该是115度。这就是他们在测试中有多一丝不苟。是的，这提出了一个有趣的困境。我的意思是，我只是想知道制造商和测试人员是如何决定多安全才算足够安全。比如，多可靠才算足够可靠？这个界限是如何为每种产品确定的？如果你看不同的产品，它总是一个滑动标尺。飞机的可靠性必须高于你笔记本电脑的键盘。对吧？
A medicine bottle that could get in the reach of a two-year-old has to be more child resistant than a jar of jelly. Yeah. And it's always this kind of negotiation between things asking, what's the product, what's the user, what's the cost? Yeah. And what's the risk? Right, right. The designing of these tests is, you know, they can get pretty ingenious.
一个两岁孩子能拿到的药瓶必须比一罐果酱更具防儿童开启功能。是的。这总是一种关于产品是什么、用户是谁、成本是多少的协商。是的。还有风险是什么？对，对。这些测试的设计，你知道，可以变得非常有创意。
And there's ways in which you're trying to sort of balance this idea of repeatability versus real world uses. I wanted to talk about the bird ingestion test in this regard when it comes to aviation testing. Can you describe what is going on there and what they're testing for? Sure. So if you remember the miracle on the Hudson story or Captain's, Captain Sully had a bunch of geese take out both engines of his planes, and he miraculously, although real pilots will say, well, he just did what, anyway, that's going down a rabbit hole. Captain Sully had a bunch of geese take out both engines on his plane, and he very impressively safely landed on the Hudson. And that's a bird strike. Bird strikes are super common in aviation.
而且在某种程度上，你试图平衡可重复性与现实世界使用之间的这种想法。我想在这方面谈谈航空测试中的鸟类摄入测试。你能描述一下那里发生了什么以及他们在测试什么吗？当然。所以如果你记得哈德逊河上的奇迹故事，或者萨利机长，萨利机长让一群鹅撞毁了他飞机的两台发动机，他奇迹般地，尽管真正的飞行员会说，好吧，他只是做了什么，总之，那是在钻牛角尖。萨利机长让一群鹅撞毁了他飞机的两台发动机，他非常令人印象深刻地安全降落在哈德逊河上。那就是鸟击。鸟击在航空业非常普遍。
The first bird strike was recorded by the Wright brothers. And, you know, a seagull got tangled in the cables of their plane. And so what we do about it is that we test jet engines against bird ingestion, which is a very sanitized version of, we have a cannon and we shoot euthanized chickens into a running jet engine. And there are very specific curls around this. There are different versions of this test for different jet engines. and it's all very carefully calibrated. But basically the idea is,
第一次鸟击是由莱特兄弟记录的。而且，你知道，一只海鸥缠在了他们飞机的电缆里。所以我们对此所做的是，我们测试喷气发动机对抗鸟类摄入，这是一个非常美化的版本，即我们有一个大炮，我们把安乐死的鸡射进运行中的喷气发动机。围绕这一点有非常具体的规则。针对不同的喷气发动机有不同版本的测试。而且一切都经过非常仔细的校准。但基本上这个想法是，
how do you know whether or not a jet engine can either keep running or shut down safely, i.e. not catch on fire or explode. If a bird flies into it, the best way to do that is to turn it on and have a cannon that shoots chickens in, and it shoots them in at around 200 miles an hour because that's roughly the speed of a jet at takeoff,
你怎么知道喷气发动机是能继续运行还是能安全关闭，即不着火或爆炸。如果一只鸟飞进去，最好的方法是把它打开，用大炮把鸡射进去，它以大约每小时200英里的速度射入，因为那大约是喷气式飞机起飞时的速度，
because takeoff and landing are the most common times for bird strikes because the rest of the time they planes fly higher than birds do. So for a test like this, how do they strike this balance between making sure that the test is conducted similarly enough that it's repeatable but also that it replicates real-world conditions as closely as possible? Yeah, you want a test to be, to recreate as similarly as possible, the real-world conditions that,
因为起飞和降落是鸟击最常见的时间，因为其余时间飞机飞得比鸟高。所以对于这样的测试，他们是如何在确保测试进行得足够相似以至于可重复，但同时也尽可能接近现实世界条件之间取得平衡的呢？是的，你希望测试尽可能相似地重现飞机将面临的现实世界条件，对吧？鸟、喷气发动机、大炮。大炮是为了重现飞机的速度。鸟是为了重现将要撞进去的现实生活中的鸟。但你也希望你的测试非常标准化且非常可重复。这样，假设你正在制造一台新的喷气发动机，你进行了这次迭代，它表现还可以，但你调整了这个东西，你要测试它的新版本。你希望知道你得到的结果是完全一样的。我们在这个测试中使用鸡的原因是因为它们很容易获得，它们相当相似，而且它们几乎完全符合FAA要求你测试喷气
the plane will face, right? Bird, jet engine, cannon. The cannon is there to recreate the speed of the plane. The bird is there to recreate the real-life bird who's going to go into it. But you also want your test to be very standardized and very repeatable. So that, say, you're making a new jet engine and you had this iteration and it did okay, but you've tweaked this thing and you're going to test this new version of it. You want to know that the the test results you're getting are exactly the same. The reason we use chickens for this test is because they're highly available, they're pretty similar, and they almost exactly meet the FAA's requirement that you test the jet
发动机对抗四磅重的鸟的要求。但问题是鸡不会飞。鸡最终不会进入喷气发动机。那是真的。而且FAA曾经对飞机以各种方式撞击的所有不同动物进行过一项为期20年的研究。飞机与髯海豹的遭遇比飞机与鸡的遭遇更多。那是一只海豹和零只鸡。但同样，鸡符合测试要求。
engine against a four-pound bird. But the thing is that chickens don't fly. Chickens don't end up in jet engines. That's true. And the FAA at one point did a 20-year study of all the different animals that have been hit by planes in various ways. And there are more plain on bearded seal encounters than plane on chicken encounters. That's one seal and zero chickens. But again, like chickens fit the test.
鸡很容易获得。基本上，这是一件我们稍微耸耸肩说，嗯，这相当安全的事情。所以你拥有测试的可重复性或可行性，以及与现实世界条件的相似性总是处于紧张状态。就像选择一个标准一样，这是一种你必须说，嗯，这让它变得更容易做到，即使它稍微脱离了现实世界。这就是寻找那种平衡。
Chickens are easily available. and basically this is something where we shrug our shoulders a little bit and go, well, this is pretty safe. And so you have the repeatability or the workability of the test and the similarity to real-world conditions are always intention. And just like picking a standard, it's this thing where you have to go, well, this makes it a little more doable, even if it takes away from the real world just a little bit. And it's finding that balance.
所以测试工程的另一个要素是你所说的“防呆设计”，这本质上是确保产品不仅能经受住它应该做的事情，而且如果有人用错了，它仍然会相对安全。那么你如何尝试对产品进行防呆设计呢？所以要对产品进行防呆设计，你首先要做的是非常仔细地考虑用户。这是一件我不想区分的事情。Sparage工程师。但我会说的是，我将基于一个事实，即我与一个叫肯·唐·特里莫的人交谈，他教授产品安全工程。他告诉我他的学生并不
So another element of test engineering is something that you call foolproofing, which is essentially making sure that a product not only stands up to what it's supposed to do, but also if someone were to use it wrong, it would still be somewhat safe. So how do you go about trying to foolproof a product? So the first thing you have to do to foolproof a product is think really carefully about the user. And this is a thing that I don't want to distinguish. Sparage engineers. But what I'll say is I'll base this on a real fact is that I talk to a guy named Ken Don Trimaud who teaches product safety engineering. And he tells me his students don't
自然地考虑这些东西。工程师通常倾向于制造一个能工作的产物，而不是制造一个为人类工作的产物。所以作为一名工程师，要真正对某样东西进行防呆设计，你必须考虑，有人会用这东西做什么？尽管我告诉他们不要这样做，尽管说明书里根本没写，尽管这是一件显然很愚蠢的事情。所以，例如，你制造一把螺丝刀。螺丝刀是用来拧螺丝的。人们也用它们来打开油漆罐。
naturally think about this stuff. Engineers are often geared toward making a product that works, not making a product that works for a person. So to actually foolproof something as an engineer, you have to think about, what is someone going to do with this thing? Despite the fact that I tell them not to, despite the fact that it's nowhere in the instructions, despite the fact that it's an obviously stupid thing to do. So, for example, you make a screwdriver. A screwdriver is made to turn screws. People also use them to open paint cans.
每个打开过油漆罐的人可能都用过螺丝刀，因为那就是你打开油漆罐的方法。它是完成这项工作的工具，是的。它是完成这项工作的工具。所以它必须被制造出来，即使在你撬动可能很坚硬的东西时，它也不会破碎并将塑料或金属碎片射入你的眼睛。螺丝刀必须被制造出来以有效地打开油漆罐。但你可以想象有人把它插进耳朵里清理耳垢。当然。
Everyone who's opened a paint can has probably used a screwdriver to do it because that's how you open a paint can. It is the tool for the job, yes. It is the tool for the job. So it has to be made so that even when you're levering something that might be tough, it doesn't shatter and throw plastic or metal shards into your eyes. A screwdriver has to be made to open paint cans effectively. But you can imagine someone sticking it in their ear to clean out earwax. Sure.
并刺穿他们的耳膜，但你不必把它制造得不会刺穿它。你的耳膜，因为即使你可以作为一个理性的人预见到这一点，也没有人那样做的真正模式，因为人们至少有那么聪明。所以防呆设计总是，再次，在什么使某物安全和什么使某物可用之间找到平衡。比如，我经常去露营。我讨厌我们的防熊罐，因为我觉得它几乎无法打开。它很痛。
And puncturing their eardrum, but you don't have to make it so that it won't puncture it. your eardrum, because even though you could foresee that as a reasonable person, there's no real pattern of people doing that because people are at least that intelligent. And so it's always foolproofing is, again, finding the balance between what makes something safe and what makes something usable. Like, I go camping a lot. I hate our bear canister because I find it almost impossible to open. It gets hurt.
它让我抓狂。我说，但至少我能把它打开，而且我非常有信心内华达山脉的熊打不开这个。所以，好吧，这是一个很好的权衡。当涉及到防呆设计时，当你真的无法从产品中设计掉危险，或者也许你可以，
It drives me crazy. and I say, but at least I can get it open and I'm pretty confident that a bear here and the Sierra Nevada Mountains can't open this. So, okay, that's a fine trade-off. It's interesting when it comes to foolproofing when you really can't design the hazard out of the product, or maybe like you can,
但这意味着产品变得非常困难和令人讨厌，或者变得非常昂贵，这很有趣。是的。所以一个很好的例子是SawStop，这是一种台锯安全装置，由一个叫史蒂夫·加斯的人创造，他是一名业余木工，
but it means that the product becomes very difficult and annoying to use or becomes very expensive. Yeah. So one great example of that is saw stop, which is is a table saw safety device created by a guy named Steve Gass who was an amateur woodworker
白天是一名专利律师，如果你深入了解这个故事，这变得非常相关。但他正在使用他的台锯，他有一个非常正确的想法，我最终可能会在使用这个东西时伤害自己。有没有办法让台锯变得安全？
and by day a patent attorney, which if you go really deep into the story becomes quite relevant. But he was using his table saw and he had the very correct thought, I'll probably eventually hurt myself using this thing. And is there a way to make a table saw safe?
因为你可以得到一些东西，它们是覆盖在上面的防护罩，可能阻止你的手指伸进去，但它们也使锯子变得不那么好用，而且人们有非常明显的把它们拆掉扔掉的模式。我不需要这个东西，它只会碍事。他创造了一个叫SawStop的东西，
because there are these things you can get that are kind of guards over them that maybe stop your fingers putting in but they also make the saw somewhat less usable and there's a very clear pattern of people pulling them off and throwing them away. I don't need this thing just gets in my way. He created a thing called saw stop
他在刀片中运行了一个带有微处理器的电路，并在刀片下方放置了一个看起来本质上是铝制刹车的东西。这个想法是，如果你的手指碰到它，碰到刀片，你就会完成那个电路，因为我们导电。而那个电路完成的那一刻，非常像把一根棍子插进自行车的辐条里。它只是停止了东西的运行。结果是他创造了一种在几分之一秒内停止台锯的方法，
where he ran an electric circuit through the blade with a microprocessor And he put what looks like essentially an aluminum brake below the blade. And the idea is if your finger touches it, touches the blade, you will complete that electric circuit because we conduct electricity. And the moment that circuit is completed, it's very much like putting a stick in the spokes of your bicycle. It just stops the thing from running. And the result is that he created a way to stop a table saw in a fraction of a second
在你甚至还没能真正伤害到你的手指之前。你可能会离开。你可能需要一个创可贴，但你不需要缝针，也不需要有人把你的手指缝回你的手上。这是一个不可思议的发明，消费品安全委员会称赞他，说这太棒了，这应该安装
before you could even actually do damage to your finger. You might come away. You might need a Band-Aid, but you won't need stitches, and you won't need someone to sew your finger back onto your hand. It was an incredible invention, and the Consumer Product Safety Commission like allotted him, said this is amazing, this should be attached
在制造的每一台台锯上。问题是，它很贵。它给台锯的价格增加了数百美元的成本，否则这是一种相当实惠的产品，所有的台锯制造商都说，
to every table saw ever made. The problem is, it was expensive. It added hundreds of dollars of cost to the price of a table saw, which otherwise is a pretty affordable product, and all of the table saw manufacturers go,
我们不想那样做。第一，因为这家伙拥有专利，我们必须为每一台台锯付钱给他。但第二，真正的大原因是它会让我们的消费者觉得太贵，他们不想买这些东西。
we don't want to do that. One, because this guy owns the patent, and we'll have to pay him money for every table saw. saw. But two, the real big reason is that it's going to make it too expensive for our consumers, and they won't want to buy these things.
我的意思是，你仍然可以出去买那些东西，对吧？是的。是的，史蒂夫·加斯最终做的是说，好吧，我只会卖一系列叫SawStop的台锯，它们内置了这个东西。是的。是的。而且它们更贵。它们很安全，而且实际上
I mean, you can still go out and buy one of those things, right? Yes. Yeah, what Steve Gas ended up doing was saying, fine, I'll just sell a line of table saws called sawstop that have this thing built into them. Yeah. Yeah. And they're more expensive. They're safe, and actually
他的一些最好的客户是那些仍然有手工课的学校。完全正确。这又是那种风险计算，如果你只是一个人，你会说，我真的想多付几百块钱吗？我不能只是小心点吗？而学校则说，这些是青少年。我们不想被他们的父母起诉。
some of his best clients are the schools that still have shop classes. Totally. Which is, again, that risk calculus of if you're just one person, you're going, do I really want to pay a couple hundred extra bucks? Can't I just be careful versus a school that's like, these are teenagers? And we don't want to get sued by their parents.
所以他们会支付额外的钱。所以，这又是那个滑动标尺。我喜欢的是我和产品安全工程师肯·丹特拉马尔谈过这件事。他说，我会买一个吗？不，太贵了。你知道，我们基本上到目前为止谈论的是产品，你知道，被按预期使用和运作。但有一整类测试与产品故障、汽车碰撞、飞机从天上掉下来有关。你称之为解体测试。
So they're going to pay the extra money. So, again, it's that sliding scale. And what I love is I talked about this with the product safety engineer, Ken Dantramal. and he goes, would I buy one? Nah, it's too expensive. You know, we're basically so far talking about products, you know, being used as intended functioning. But there's a whole class of testing has to do with the fact that products fail, cars crash, planes fall out of the sky. You term this disintegration testing.
你能描述一下那是什么以及他们是如何测试它的吗？解体测试基于这样一个事实的接受，即事物会失败。飞机偶尔会坠毁，大坝会决堤，所有这些设计都带有我如何能让某物安全地失败的想法。汽车碰撞测试实际上是这方面最重要的领域之一。所以汽车的解体测试始于一个叫休·德·海文的人。他想作为一名飞行员参加第一次世界大战。他听力不好什么的，所以被美国拒绝了，他最终在加拿大皇家空军服役。
Can you describe what that is and how they test for it? Disintegration testing is based on the acceptance of the fact that things fail. Planes do crash occasionally, dams burst, and it's all designed with the idea of how can I make something fail safely. And car crash testing is actually one of the most important places for this. So disintegration testing for cars started with a guy named Hugh de Haven. He wanted to fight as a pilot in the First World War. He had bad hearing or something, so he got rejected by the U.S., he ended up flying with the Canadian Royal Air Force.
在训练期间，他的飞机在半空中与另一架飞机相撞。这两架飞机之间有四个人，他是唯一幸存下来的。我的意思是，他差点就死了。他内脏破裂。他摔断了腿。医生们只是认为他会死，所以他们没有费心去固定他骨折的腿，但他活了下来。他在康复期间花了很多时间思考，嗯，为什么我幸存下来了？我的飞机里发生了什么，而其他飞机里没有发生？他开始研究这个，
And during training, his plane collided with another plane in mid-air. There were four people between these two planes, and he was the only one who survived. I mean, he very nearly died. He burst organs. He broke his leg. legs. The doctors just assumed he would die so they didn't bother to set his legs that were broken, but he lived. And he spent a lot of time in his convalescence just wondering, well, why did I survive? What happened in my plane that didn't happen in other planes? And he started researching this
在他出院后。他只是开始思考它。他会做一些事情，比如把鸡蛋扔到泡沫垫上，看看是什么打破了它们。他研究了幸存者的自杀式跳跃。他会观察那些从应该杀死他们的高度跳下但幸存下来的人的情况，以及为什么他们幸存下来。所以他提出了一个他称之为汽车或飞机内“第二次碰撞”的术语。他说特别是在车辆内，这不是第一次碰撞。不是飞机撞击地面
after he got out of the hospital. He just started thinking about it. And he would do things like drop eggs onto foam mats to see what broke them. And he studied suicidal jumps by people who had survived. And he'd look at the conditions of the people who jumped from a certain height that should have killed them and why they survived effectively. And so he came up with this term that he called the second collision within a car or an airplane. And he said specifically within vehicles, it's not the first collision. It's not the plane hitting the ground
或汽车撞上另一辆车伤害了乘客。是乘客撞击了车辆内部。对。当他们被牛顿物理学向前推进时。他说，那才是我们真正需要注意的。看看像他把鸡蛋扔到某些材料上没碎，
or the car hitting the other car that hurts the occupant. It's the occupant hitting the inside of the vehicle. Right. As they're propelled forward by Newtonian physics. And he said, that's what we actually need to pay attention to. And looking at things like hit the eggs that didn't break when he dropped them onto certain materials
以及那些从高处跳下但幸存下来的人，因为他们落在刚耕过的草坪上，或者他们在撞击地面之前撞到了木结构，这减缓了他们的坠落。他说，基本上，我们需要缓冲这些人，我们需要约束他们。这就是我们最终得到安全气囊和安全带的地方，
and the people who jumped from Great Heights but survived because they landed on a freshly tilled lawn or they hit a wooden structure before hitting the ground that kind of slowed their fall. He said, basically, we need to cushion these people and we need to restrain them. And that's where we get, ultimately, airbags and seatbelts,
这些东西使汽车不再那么极其危险。但他还说，嗯，如果你想想他工作真正起飞的1950年代的汽车设计，他说，车内少一些金属尖刺怎么样？而且，甚至在安全气囊时代之前，一个在你撞击它时会压缩而不是刺穿你的方向盘怎么样？是的，是的。这实际上很常见而且非常可怕。但这需要这种完全不同的思维方式，因为真的直到他的工作，以及在他之后很多年，直到联邦政府设法强迫汽车公司服从，
which are the things that made cars less incredibly dangerous. But he also said, well, if you think about car design in the 1950s when his work was really taking off, he said, how about fewer metal spikes? inside the car. And how about, even before the age of airbags, how about a steering wheel that'll compress
汽车公司一直在说，这是司机的问题。我们只需要司机教育。我们只需要教育司机如何成为更好的司机，是方向盘后面的那些疯子导致了车祸。这基本上就是“我早就告诉过你”的论点。
when you hit it rather than impale you? Yeah, yeah. Which was actually pretty common and very gruesome. But it took this whole different way of thinking because really up until his work, and for years and years after it, until the federal government managed to bludge in car companies into obeisance,
是的，是的，是的。这在防呆设计中也经常出现。我发现了一位保险商实验室工程师的引言，他说，为什么我要费心设计一个不会变热的烤面包机，而不去触碰它就能达到同样的结果？这就像因为人们会触碰热的烤面包机，不是因为他们是白痴，
car companies were saying, it's the driver. All we need is driver education. We just need to educate drivers about how to be better drivers, and it's those nuts behind the wheel who cause car accidents. It's basically the I Told You So argument.
或者因为他们试图伤害自己，而是因为这是一瞬间的疏忽，因为你一只手抱着孩子，你试图移动某样东西，事情发生了，失败发生了。你必须设计一个好的产品来防止它。你知道，我们在这个节目中经常谈论基础设施，我对测试工程在使事物安全失败方面的方面非常感兴趣。就像，测试一个你正在生产数百万份的产品是一回事。你可以，你知道，继续测试它并进行迭代，随着时间的推移它会变得更好。但当涉及到基础设施时，我的意思是，你只有一次机会建造一座桥梁或大坝。你如何设计考虑到失败的基础设施？设计基础设施的基准常见方式是查看条件，通常是历史气候条件。假设我们谈论的是大坝。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And it comes up a lot in foolproofing, too. I found a quote from an underwriter's labs engineer who said, why should I bother to design a toaster that doesn't get hot when the same result can be achieved by not touching it? And it's like because people are going to touch hot toasters and not because they're idiots
你说，好吧，风速达到这个，你知道，风暴达到这个水平，温度达到这个。所以我们将用混凝土建造一个足够坚固的大东西，以超过所有这些条件。即使我们知道风在这个峡谷中达到每小时100英里，我们也会把它设计成每小时150英里，并确保它是安全的。
or because they're trying to hurt themselves because it's a moment of inattention because you're holding your baby in one arm and you're trying to move something like things happen, failure happens. And you have to design a good. against it. You know, we talk about infrastructure a lot on this show, and I was really interested in the aspect of test engineering when it comes to making things safe to fail. Like, it's one thing to be
问题是，特别是随着气候变化，历史性的，这种被称为“设计风暴”的想法，也就是你在设计基础设施时脑海中的风暴。
testing a product where you're producing millions of copies of the thing. You can, you know, keep testing it and taking it through iterations where it gets better over time. But when it comes to infrastructure, I mean, you get one chance to build a bridge or a dam. Like, how do you design infrastructure with failure in mind. The baseline commonplace way to design infrastructure is to look at the conditions, which are usually historic climate conditions. Let's say we're talking about a dam.
设计风暴不再是一个非常有用的衡量标准，因为天气变得越来越狂野。说，你知道，更多的野火。更强烈的飓风，更快的风，等等。所以现在土木工程界有一种思想流派说，好吧，让我们停止仅仅试图让事物变得越来越强，堆积越来越多的混凝土。
You say, okay, wind speeds hit this, you know, storms hit this level, temperatures hit this. So we'll build a big thing out of concrete that's strong enough to exceed all of those conditions. Even if we know winds hit 100 miles an hour in this canyon, we'll design it to 150 miles an hour and make sure it's safe.
让我们转而设计考虑到失败的事物。这并不一定意味着你只是屈服于基础设施会崩溃的事实，对吧？就像你谈论荷兰的一个考虑到失败的基础设施例子。你能多说说那个项目吗？是的。这是一个叫“为河流留出空间”的项目，他们发现随着时间的推移，他们的河流不断泛滥。而且它们泛滥得越来越多。破坏也变得越来越严重。它淹没了城市。它摧毁了庄稼。他们正在建造越来越高的堤坝。他们正在建造堤坝和所有这些方式来
The problem is that, with climate change, especially, historic, this idea of what's called a design storm, which is the storm you have in mind when you're designing a piece of infrastructure.
试图控制他们的河流。最终他们说，这不再起作用了。最终，他们决定从一个完全不同的角度来看待它，接受他们为阻止河流泛滥而设计的人造设计最终会失败。
The design storm isn't a very helpful gauge anymore because weather's getting so much wilder. Saying, you know, more wildfires. more intense hurricanes, faster winds, et cetera. And so there's a school of thought now in civil engineering that says, well, let's stop just trying to make things stronger and stronger and stronger and piling more and more and more concrete.
相反，他们为河流创造了空间。实际上有几条我无法发音的河流。好吧。他们说，我们要在它们周围建造这些大田地。紧挨着这些
Let's instead design things with failure in mind. And that doesn't necessarily mean that you just resign to the fact that infrastructure will crumble, right? Like you talk about an example of infrastructure in the Netherlands that was designed with failure. in mind. Could you say more about that project? Yeah. It was a project called Room for the River, where they found that over time, their rivers kept flooding. And they kept flooding more and more and more. And the damage was becoming worse and worse. It was flooding cities. It was destroying crops. And they were building levees, taller and taller and taller. And they were building dikes and all these ways to
河流的农民，我们要买下他们的土地，我们要帮助他们在别处买地。对于拒绝留下的农民，我们要为他们制定补偿计划。他们说，我们知道这会泛滥。我们如何接受这些，我们如何使成本不至于灾难性，而不是我们如何从一开始就阻止这种情况发生？这是经典的解体测试。你接受坏事会发生，并寻找减轻损害的方法。对。这听起来是一个复杂得多的方法，因为它不仅仅是你建造某样东西，然后你让它变得更强更好。
try and rain in their rivers. And eventually they said, this is not working anymore. Ultimately, they decided to look at it from a completely different perspective, accepting that their human-made designs to stop the rivers from flooding would eventually fail.
你必须做出各种让步，并确保每个人都在船上。这更复杂，因为如果你只是说我们要阻止河流溢出，每个人都会说，太好了，建一个大堤坝。更高的墙，是的，更厚的墙。没有人有意见。这说得通。它不影响任何人。但如果你说，实际上，我们要让这些东西狂野奔流。你必须考虑这对谁有害，你必须把更多的利益相关者带入对话。你必须思考，比如，这块田地被淹没可以吗，但这块不行？这一系列建筑的地下室进水可以吗，但这系列不行？
And instead, they created room for the river. It's actually several rivers that I can't pronounce. Fair enough. They said, we're going to build these big fields around them. Farmers who are right next to these
所以从社会层面来看，这要困难得多，但如果你能做对，效果会好得多。休息后会有更多关于亚历克斯·戴维斯的内容。我们回来了，和亚历克斯·戴维斯在一起。你在书中谈到的一件事是，无论你在实验室里测试某样东西多少次，现实世界最终会向它抛出比任何实验室所能设计的更多的事情。你用了我喜欢的金门大桥的例子，桥上增加了一个新的设计元素。但它最终产生了一个重大的意外影响，
rivers, we're going to buy them out and we're going to help them buy land elsewhere. And the farmers who refuse to stay, we're going to create compensation programs for them. They said, we know this will flood. How do we accept these and how do we make the costs not catastrophic rather than how do we stop this from happening in the first place? And it's classic disintegration testing. You accept that the bad thing will happen and you look for ways to mitigate the damage. Right. It sounds like a much more complicated approach because it's not just like you're building something and you just make it stronger and better.
那就是它把桥变成了一个巨大的乐器。你能谈谈那里发生了什么吗？所以2014年，金门大桥的所有者决定在桥下增加网，以减轻或防止从桥上跳下的自杀行为。他们知道增加网会增加桥上的风荷载，他们想确保桥在更高的风速下保持其结构完整性。他们最终做的是把桥上道路周围的板条，栏杆，桥上的行人通道，最初与桥平行，
You have to make all sorts of concessions and make sure everyone's on board. It's more complicated because if you're just saying we're going to stop the river from overflowing, everyone says, great, build a big levy. Taller wall, yeah, thicker wall. No one has a problem with that. That makes sense. It doesn't affect anyone. But if you're saying, actually, we're going to let these things run wild. You have to think about who is that going to harm, and you have to bring more stakeholders into the conversation. You have to think, like, is it okay that this field floods, but this one doesn't? Is it okay that this series of buildings gets water in their basement, but this series of buildings doesn't?
就像栅栏上的板条一样。他们把它们拿走，转了90度。这样它们就不会挡风。所以我们正在平衡它。是的。是的。所以他们说，当然，我们需要正确地测试这一点。所以他们把一个比例模型带进了风洞。他们从各种不同的方向向它吹风。他们说，太棒了。它支撑得非常好。没问题。所以他们去了，把上面的所有板条都转了。然后几乎立刻你就得到了一个有风的日子，因为那是旧金山。
And so on a societal level, it's much harder, but it works a lot better if you can get it right. More with Alex Davies after the break. We're back with Alex Davies. Something you talk about in your book is the idea that no matter how much you test something in a lab, the real world will ultimately throw way more things at it than any lab could possibly devise. And you use this example of the Golden Gate Bridge, which I love, where a new design element was added to the bridge. But it ended up having a major unintended effect,
你得到了旧金山湾另一边的人们听到的这种噪音。他们说，这到底是什么诡异的嗡嗡声？就像你在恐怖电影中听到的噪音，事情第一次开始出错的时候。他们没有意识到，他们没有考虑桥的声学。他们考虑的是桥上的风荷载。这就是我所说的动力学测试。你实际上是在测试某样东西如何影响其环境，以及某样东西如何受到你放置它的环境的影响。
which is that it turned the bridge into a gigantic musical instrument. Can you talk about what happened there? So in 2014, the owners of the Golden Gate Bridge decided to add nets under the bridge to mitigate or prevent suicidal jumps from the bridge. They knew that adding nets would increase the wind load on the bridge, and they wanted to make sure the bridge would maintain its structural integrity under higher winds. And what they ended up doing was taking the slats that are along the round the road, railing, the pedestrian walkway on the bridge, which were originally parallel to the bridge,
所以他们最终做的是，他们稍微回到了绘图板。他们说，好吧，我们仍然想要这里的网。我们仍然认为把板条转成垂直是减少风荷载并使其平衡的最佳方式。但他们最终做的是，他们在每一个板条上放了这些小的橡胶衬里夹子，一个U形夹子，
like the slats on a picket fence. And they took them, and they turned them 90 degrees. And so that way, they're not catching the wind. And so we're balancing it out. Yeah. Yeah. And so they said, of course, we need to test this properly. So they took a scale model into a wind tunnel. And they blew wind at it from all sorts of different directions. They said, great. It holds up super well. No problem. So they went, and they turned all of the slats on the thing. And then almost immediately you get a windy day because it's San Francisco.
基本上是为了阻止它振动。因为发生的事情是风穿过，像一个巨大的口琴，所有这些东西都在轻微振动，这就是发出嗡嗡声的原因。这一次，他们实际上测试了它的声学效果，他们发现几乎在所有风况下，桥都是安静的。
And you get this noise that people on the other side of the San Francisco Bay are hearing. And they're going, what on earth is this eerie humming noise? It's like the noise you get in a horror movie, the first time things start to go a little bit wrong. And what they didn't realize, they didn't think about the acoustics of the bridge. They thought about the wind load on the bridge. And this is what I call dynamics testing. You're effectively testing how does something affect its environment and how is something affected by the environment in which you put it.
在一些非常特殊的阵风条件下，它会发出一点噪音。但他们说，这是可以接受的。他们装上了所有的夹子，并把它们全部漆成了金门大桥标志性的橙色。我在你的书中发现的一个非常有趣的测试方面是意图的概念。基本上，当用户不仅是在错误地使用产品，而且是在恶意地使用它时，如何测试产品？我认为一个很好的例子是AirTag，这是一个旨在帮助寻找丢失个人物品的小追踪标签。如果你考虑测试AirTag，你首先想到的可能是，好吧，如果我把它掉了，它还能用吗？你知道，电池能持续多久？
And so what they ended up doing was, so they went back a little bit to the drawing board. They said, well, we still want the nets here. we still think turning the slats perpendicular is the best way to reduce wind load and even that out. But what they ended up doing was they put these little rubber-lined clips, a U-shaped clip on every single slat
所以他们最终的做法是，他们稍微退回到最初的方案。他们说，好吧，我们仍然希望这里有网。我们仍然认为将板条垂直放置是减少风荷载并使其均匀化的最佳方法。但他们最终做的是，在每一根板条上都安装了这些带有橡胶衬里的夹子，一种U型夹。
to basically stop it vibrating. Because what was happening was the wind was coming through and like a giant harmonica, all of these things were vibrating a little bit and that's what was making the humming noise. This time, They actually tested the acoustics of it, and they found that in almost all wind conditions, the bridge was silent.
基本上是为了阻止它振动。因为当时发生的情况是，风吹过时，就像一个巨大的口琴，所有这些东西都在轻微振动，这就是发出嗡嗡声的原因。这一次，他们实际测试了它的声学效果，发现几乎在所有风况下，桥梁都是静音的。
In some very particular gusty conditions, it would make a little bit of noise. But they said, this is acceptable. They put all the clips on, and they painted them all the iconic orange of the Golden Gate Bridge. One aspect of testing that I found really intriguing in your book was this idea of intention. Basically, how to test for a product when the user is not just using the product wrong, but is using it maliciously. And I think a great example of this is the air tag, which is a little tracing tag that's meant to help find lost personal items. And if you thought about testing an air tag, the first things you might think of are like, okay, so if I drop it, does it still work? You know, how long does the battery last?
在某些非常特殊的阵风条件下，它会发出一点噪音。但他们说，这是可以接受的。他们装上了所有的夹子，并将它们全部漆成了金门大桥标志性的橙色。在你的书中，我发现测试的一个方面非常引人入胜，那就是关于意图的概念。基本上，当用户不仅是错误地使用产品，而且是恶意地使用产品时，该如何测试产品。我认为AirTag就是一个很好的例子，它是一个小型的追踪标签，旨在帮助寻找丢失的个人物品。如果你考虑测试AirTag，你首先想到的可能是，好吧，如果我把它掉了，它还能用吗？你知道，电池能用多久？
If I move it 30 feet, does it still connect? How about 100 yards? But what I don't really think about is how you test it keeping in mind that it might be used maliciously. Could you talk about that? almost, I think maybe possibly, even before they were on the market. When people knew that Apple was making a thing called an air tag, that you could attach to your keys or even attached to your dog or put in your kid's backpack to keep track of where things are,
如果我把它移动30英尺，它还能连接吗？100码呢？但我真正没考虑到的是，在考虑到它可能被恶意使用的情况下，你该如何测试它。你能谈谈这个吗？几乎是在它们上市之前，甚至可能更早。当人们知道苹果公司正在制造一种叫做AirTag的东西，你可以把它挂在钥匙上，甚至挂在狗身上，或者放进孩子的书包里来追踪物品的位置时，
people immediately said, stalkers are going to use these to track people. Because they're really small. They don't make any noise. It's really easy to slip into something. thing. And eventually, Apple got hit with a class action lawsuit by people who a lot of, it was almost exclusively women who were being tracked by abusive, either partners or former partners. And this was a genuine problem for a lot of people. And Apple ultimately went back and thought a little bit more about it. They did put some measures in from the beginning to give them credit.
人们立刻说，跟踪者会用这些东西来追踪他人。因为它们非常小，不会发出任何声音，很容易塞进某样东西里。最终，苹果公司遭到了一起集体诉讼，原告几乎全是女性，她们被虐待性的伴侣或前伴侣追踪。这对许多人来说是一个真正的问题。苹果公司最终回过头来，对此进行了更深入的思考。平心而论，他们从一开始就采取了一些措施。
There was a thing that after a couple of days, it would say, hey, there's an air tag that's matching your location almost all the time, but it's not on your account. Should you check that? And I get those alerts sometimes, even like I travel a lot with my husband, and sometimes it says, hey, this case of AirPods has been going everywhere you're going. I'm like, yeah, because we're on vacation. We're going to all the same places. But it's true. It's the kind of conventional testing we've been talking about tends to fall short when
有一项功能是，几天后，它会提示：嘿，有一个AirTag几乎一直与你的位置匹配，但它不在你的账户下。你应该检查一下吗？我有时也会收到这些提醒，即使我和丈夫经常一起旅行，有时它会说，嘿，这副AirPods一直跟着你去往各地。我会说，是的，因为我们在度假，我们去的地方都一样。但这是真的，我们一直在谈论的那种常规测试往往在以下情况下显得不足：
you're talking about not just is someone going to use this in a stupid way, but is someone going to use this in a malicious way? It's easy to take test engineering for granted, I think. but so many things we interact with have gone through rigorous testing and we have benefited tremendously from it. The vaccines we get, the planes we fly in, the bridges we drive across, the refrigerators that we have at home. In your book, you also write that we're in an era where it feels like test engineering is maybe more important than ever, especially now that we're kind of in a real world scenario where it feels like we're being tested all the time. And I'm thinking of algorithms and AI technologies that are being tested in the real world on us, learning from us, in ways that are faster than we can possibly understand.
当你谈论的不仅仅是“是否有人会以愚蠢的方式使用它”，而是“是否有人会以恶意的方式使用它”时。我认为很容易把测试工程视为理所当然，但我们接触的许多事物都经过了严格的测试，我们从中受益匪浅。我们接种的疫苗、乘坐的飞机、行驶过的桥梁、家里的冰箱。在你的书中，你也写道，我们正处于一个测试工程可能比以往任何时候都更重要的时代，尤其是现在，我们正处于一种现实世界的场景中，感觉我们一直在被测试。我想到的是算法和人工智能技术，它们正在现实世界中对我们进行测试，并以我们无法理解的方式向我们学习。
Why do you think it's important that we know how things are tested? I think knowing how these tests are done is important because these tests underpin how basically everything you ever buy is made. and I think it's becoming more important because testing is breaking out of the laboratory. The best example here is self-driving cars, right? If you've seen a self-driving car, which basically means have you been to San Francisco or Austin or those different places,
你为什么认为了解事物是如何被测试的很重要？我认为了解这些测试是如何完成的很重要，因为这些测试支撑着你购买的几乎所有东西的制造方式。而且我认为它变得越来越重要，因为测试正在走出实验室。这里最好的例子是自动驾驶汽车，对吧？如果你见过自动驾驶汽车，这基本上意味着你去过旧金山、奥斯汀或那些不同的地方，
if you've seen a self-driving car go by, you are part of that test. Part of that test is, is this thing going to drive up onto the sidewalk, and mow you down. Fortunately, they don't put these things out in the real world until they're very confident about that. But testing is happening in all of these different ways around you.
如果你见过一辆自动驾驶汽车经过，你就是那项测试的一部分。那项测试的一部分是：这东西会不会开上人行道，把你撞倒？幸运的是，在他们对这一点非常有信心之前，他们不会把这些东西放到现实世界中。但测试正以各种不同的方式在你周围发生。
A new Facebook algorithm is being tested in real time on real people. And so I think there's a lot to be said for being more knowledgeable about how these engineers work, how these tests are run. You can start to question what are the tradeoffs between safety and reliability and progress and profit? You can start thinking, how close is this to the real world?
一个新的Facebook算法正在实时对真实的人进行测试。所以我认为，更多地了解这些工程师如何工作、这些测试如何运行是非常有意义的。你可以开始质疑安全性、可靠性、进步和利润之间的权衡是什么？你可以开始思考，这离现实世界有多近？
What tradeoffs? What did they sacrifice to make this a workable test? I call testing the hidden backstory of everything in your life. It lets you see that backstory or it lets you imagine it with a lot more clarity. Well, Alex Davies, thank you so much for talking with. me, I had such a fun time and I really enjoyed your book. Thank you so much for having me. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Losham and Dawn.
什么权衡？他们为了使这成为一个可行的测试牺牲了什么？我称测试为生活中一切事物的隐藏背景故事。它让你看到那个背景故事，或者让你更清晰地想象它。好的，Alex Davies，非常感谢你与我交谈，我玩得很开心，也非常喜欢你的书。非常感谢邀请我。本周的《99% Invisible》由Losham和Dawn制作。
Additional production by Jacob Medina Gleason. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kirk Colestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivienne,
额外制作由Jacob Medina Gleason负责。混音由Martine Gonzalez完成。音乐由Swan Real创作。Kathy 2是我们的执行制片人。Kirk Colestead是数字总监。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括Chris Barubei、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Vivienne，
Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as your own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg、Talon and Rain Stradley，以及我，Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》的标志由Stefan Lawrence创作。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》过去的所有剧集，网址是99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。